je suis vraiment désolé pour tout savoir
oh pitié on est là pour sauver la vie de
notre ami et rien d'autre
on l'a payé pour nous faire entrer ici
et sortir d'ici elle aurait dû dire oh
je vais le faire discrètement personne
ne saura que je l'ai faite mais non
madame préfère tirer sur tout le monde
et menacer des innocents
et vous devez sûrement vous demander
pourquoi je me suis fier à elle et ben
ça c'est une bonne question et la
réponse c'est qu'avant elle et moi on
s'aimait c'était ma petite amie ok elle
s'en souvient pas parce qu'elle était
une autre son père l'a balancé d'une
falaise magique elle s'est tuée et j'ai
pété un plomb et j'ai failli détruire
l'univers et la voilà elle est revenue
d'un lointain passer et oui c'était dans
ce passé tout le monde est mort et elle
non peut-être grâce à la magie de la
falaise ça j'en sais rien parce que je
suis pas un spécialiste des pierres
d'infinité
j'ai rien qu'un pauvre terrien qui a
rencontré une fille en or qui est tombée
amoureux mais cette fille est morte et
elle vient de revenir totalement taré
elle a oublié quelques infos importantes
mais
il a résumé l'essentiel